sunshine wind chill Withers music and
his melodies has such an ease and
simplicity they almost seemed
supernatural in fact withers didn't
start writing music until he was 32 if
you're musical you're born that way you
can get into false humility and stuff
but you don't try this if you don't
think you can do it his first single
ain't no sunshine hit number three on
the charts withers follow-up record lean
on me went to number one
[Music]
over the next 15 years withers strung
together a lifetime's worth of hit
then in 1985 withers recorded his last
album and did not sing in public for 25
years he spoke to Anthony Mason for CBS
this morning Saturday in 2015 just
before being honored at Carnegie Hall
it's a tribute to you yes how do you
feel about that looks like a pre
obituary withers family says he died
Monday at age 81 from heart
complications
growing up in slab fork West Virginia
withers was a small boy who overcame a
stutter he joined the Navy and worked as
an aircraft mechanic and for a magical
decade-and-a-half his voice gave us a
gift to enjoy long after he's gone I'm
satisfied that I was at least valid I
wanted to write some songs that were
reasonably profound and I think I did
that
[Music]
he certainly did and leave it to Anthony
Mason to get him to talk I mean can you
believe it lean on me inspired a movie
about a New Jersey principal who you
know brought back a school I mean it's
so embodied so much of what we're about
and today right now Lean on Me the
perfect song for all of us to remember
him with certainly I would say death 100
percent nice called Dana nice piece
Michelle